Oh what oh oh so we're gonna do same
colors yeah sure
how do you roll dice without like if you
left click and hold it and then tap are
you'll kind of like shake it and then
you can just drop it yeah but then you
kind of know what it's gonna land on
because you could just tap hard so you
see the numbers look fine look we need
calm you know like this dog [ __ ] where
to go it stays stuck in the thing yeah
you know I'm not gonna say it doesn't
work all right
maybe that's not a good maybe that's our
thing just keep going our until the last
number you see when you let go of ours
how are you seeing numbers because I
keep hitting our until I let go of what
people are getting are you can't this
little one you can't see the dice about
that all right so we'll just set this on
the side and we'll do this little one
that's hard to reach wait shake cuz wait
baby I just told people cheating we
should also look up the rules of the
game probably they seem pretty simple
roll and you put your pegs some mouse
over it you press R once oh okay oh okay
well yeah we can get our big dog back
let me just just delete this little
shitty one there you go there it is you
know what you know what would help with
keeping that in the right place just put
in a bowl like this bowl set that down
and then you can for the dice and then
the bowl I'm really happy that I was
trying to move the bowl there so it's
perfectly centered it's not perfectly
safe so moving the bowl bowl is
perfectly centered there ish yeah it's
pretty centered yeah how do we play I
have no idea all right
roll the die in the middle to determine
which player goes first player with the
highest roll goes first your move your
pieces from home to start you must roll
a six
so you have to roll a six to wear which
one is the start one I imagine it's this
this this one yeah sure yeah let's say
the left it's the left one on the on the
dick of your of your area so does that
mean you go from here to here so you
move from your start to your left dick
you have at the end you I think this is
the last one here so you go to finish no
cuz actually you don't you move through
these are you snow that's your finish
are you supposed to finish that's your
finish you're supposed to put them
segmented like ones there in that hole
ones in this hole is that the objective
to get them all in these things so I
think yes invented the ball really dick
that's the whole thing up you know what
just stay stay right there left nut is
start right nut is where you turn up
into the finish holes alright is this
the game where if you don't nail it into
the finish holes you got to loop back
around possibly oh I'm gonna look at the
game the gameplay you have to roll the
exact number to get the pegs in the
holes don't worry about it you get to
roll again if you roll a six okay okay
you must count each space you move
whether it's empty or full if you are
able to land on space as an opponent's
piece they go back to the home its
includes if you start on to someone
who's on your starting piece you may not
land on your own pieces to win the game
you had first player to move all your
pieces into the finish you must roll in
the exact number to move your pieces
into an empty finished spot if you roll
a number higher than you can move and
you have no other pieces you can move
that your turn is over and your piece
does not move okay so you don't loop
around no there's no looping you just
have to roll the exact number you need
to get into a fight once you're in a
finish you can move you can advance if
you're like if you're like here and you
roll one you can like move all the way
up if you so choose so you can you can
keep wedging it in the hole who's going
first
we roll to see you guys first right is a
three I got a why I put the
and I'm going to get it Wow first wait
so what are the colors I'm green same
colors red I'm red blue yeah
aha well nothing okay do you have to get
a six gets your gets your guys out of
home to you hyper-realistic certain and
then you get to go again right away or
just yes okay interesting
six is six is a roll again okay so now
I'm going right I know yeah watch this
baby all right boys
exciting start this can't be how this
game starts alright good job everybody
yellow things stop yep you know what go
away go away
alright I guess I can't take them the
one out so you can't you can't
so one two three four five six you're
you're counting they're upset me and a
great don't get to go again then you're
still moving excitement Wow what the
[ __ ] nah I'm pretty sure that's it's
fine it's fine
okay left right yeah everybody everybody
everybody all everyone everyone throwing
sixes one two three four I can't do that
okay there Mike Thome are you one two
three four five one two three four five
no no that's how it works that's how it
works fine that's how it's supposed to
be
Oh see they're meant to be together no
you just put your spam and that goes
where it was it's fine no [ __ ] [ __ ] you
oh don't act like you're the one who's
in here my life is suffering it's
trouble mark you gonna roll the goddamn
die whose turn is it my turn bugger all
right oh my chat is not saying that the
game is not on screen is that really
happening the game was on all right
whatever it's my turn right no wait wait
no there's no rules in here no there's
no rules in the notebook the notebook is
useless I'm gonna just go ahead and I
don't know what's better I'm gonna do
this you guys can keep sandwich in me
I'll stop I'm just gonna [ __ ] run our
goddamn lives you're counting upsets me
why it's just the way you hover over
things i watch you guys do the same [ __ ]
Bob for me actually you know I I don't
really I don't want it yeah you mark you
made it pretty far there I don't want to
you made five spaces you wouldn't want
to risk it I don't play save don't move
six spaces you might go home now now
everyone's just debating what the rules
of trouble you know what the rules are
whatever the [ __ ] we do at the moment
there's no guys are the rules we're
playing volume a three one two three did
you hate that mark I hope you hated that
you counted it out loud I loved it model
I need to do that oh do it now this is
the situation that I didn't want to be
cuz then you get the humiliation you see
you see that you see you see it's okay
mark it's okay you see I've rigged it so
that I will always win no matter what
right okay would you stand up there you
go no I guess we don't have any rules
here Bob doesn't mean you do whatever
you want
hey you're the ones making up rules on
my roles so no one to call the waiter
can I go too right here you can go right
there yeah cool
counts you just you have to roll one or
two to move it forward even further
that's well three oh all right all right
hey I'm not out to get you you were kind
to me you can't move your other one whoo
yeah that's the right just gotta think
about it I just gotta think about I'm
just gonna roll this yeah all right
well let's see we got a good thing going
on here so we'll just what a nice day
nice game you know what a nice game good
good roll huh okay it's fine I'm gonna
look up what the rules are did anybody
leave you trouble game play rules
traffic happy for me I don't trust that
website okay you what we're doing it
right I love the way you say pop in six
it was what I said right correct
no it wasn't but I'll allow it
your dirty cheating ways so what are the
actual rules then dead each other Wade
I'll be nice to okay
hey hey this is God never here to begin
with I don't know why Bob decided to be
[ __ ] I don't see any reason to be
anything less than bloodthirsty and
devastating three four five six
get him wait don't you move off your own
start well whatever
because I couldn't I was blocking my own
space by the people one two three four
this games fun hi guys oh man big oops
thank you big moves you got that big
move energy oh no despite me I I was
doing it because I did it because it was
what I had to do huh and I had no other
choice no you had you had several other
choice no other choices no choice ad of
choices no choice know what you did I
don't know anything so you're wrong I'm
gonna get you I got a big fat five over
here okay move one two three four five
there I've got I've got plans my friend
oh thank god well it's fine
good big rolls big rolls
right it's not a I'm just following
closely okay I'm just gonna go here just
don't roll it to Bob I don't know if I
like the look of that one I'm gonna go
for gold because I know Bob isn't the
type of person to do course all my
friends I'm not come on just not a two
oh boy a big boy and you can't jump your
own piece in this right that was a rule
you can pass your own piece I think
can't you someone said you can't but I
don't know I don't know it's my turn
okay I need like a three or [ __ ]
higher please I don't know if I need it
that high until five all right well hey
friends it says you may not land on your
own pieces what to do so we jump over
your own pieces yeah you cannot jump
your own piece so are you totally good
it doesn't say that in the rules
explosive move I know I could have
gotten mark on that one I specifically
didn't want to chat I have a solution to
this the first place good good good good
move Bob could move Bob that's a good
[ __ ] all you might set your piece up
yeah mark we're together man he's tied
for first you're right you're right I'm
not tied for anything on top of first
all right well that didn't roll [ __ ]
all just spun in a [ __ ] wrong circle
that's good it's random baby
all right good play good play you see
you can't hurt me but I'm just saying
we're four buddies right buddy it's okay
I'm seeing blood
my shooting blood mark okay I have to
move this okay that's fair okay I'm not
here to hurt you my home my you're
welcome sitting I'm I'm I everything's
fine you want to go up on the credenza
isn't that piece of furniture so I'm not
sure credenzas like a countertop it's
like a martyr got one six that you're
definitely not going to roll right yeah
just it's fine look there's your dice
you're all set up is it my turn is it my
turn yeah yeah rolled that for it's fine
it's fine everything's fine good play
good play
I feel like there's a lot of tension
going on no look he played the six I see
what you're saying this is gonna come
back to
[Applause]
[Laughter]
listen listen listen listen
it's not my fault you did this to me you
hey okay hey Mark calm down mark calm
down everything's good man this game
I feel relaxed you feel relaxed I feel
relaxed I feel
three four I'm not even I just walk
right through your home I'm just waving
at you as I never come inside again ever
but you do like the credenza
it's a beautiful fencer hey so we're
cool right and that middle guy he
doesn't need to move everything's you
can't no you can't do that so it's fine
my own guy we agreed on that right three
four see it's all good really fly
completely spaced we are for the well
these guys just you wait till I get
another piece on the board I'll show you
guys what you're playing wait
okay okay okay okay yeah yeah no that
would've been that was your mistake here
comes my sex never rolled like four
sixes with all the three okay well yeah
just you wait till my turn I'm gonna
break it up this I'm just gonna one two
really slammer in there are all I've
rolled last [ __ ] hour no wait
no look look how far behind that other
guy is they don't want to be honest in
bond-like look at look at look at this
look at this guy I can I can draw this
guy you're right you're right no I don't
think that's I you don't even roll a
three-year-old a do Oh Bob's cheating
now she's definitely take home we're not
friends anymore
I consider this payback for sorry that's
what I to you I just won fair and square
did affected my expense and mine alone
never [ __ ] mono - all right we're
just gonna be here for Wow all right
look at making progress
yeah we really need to get some some
guys out there stomping around - good
play all right come on now
and it's gonna be a four
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
or anything what Bob will actually
murder me if I don't make this move
[Music]
sorry I was trying to flick marks and I
apparently punted yours off the entire
here I'll just put this back I knew that
as soon as I cross that threshold don't
know what happened hey buddy it's just
for funsies goddamn it no all right just
do it
this is gonna be a good move it's a good
move good play what a great number come
on bud
you wanna see my home I'm not coming
near you you might give a cover or suck
if you would set that guy all the way
here no yes it would have been you know
wait there's a line tool so you can do
[ __ ] that's not horrible right there
uh-huh uh-huh whose turn is it it's
yours
oh no right there mark look at that oh
that mark mark listen revenge is a dish
best not served right okay well let's
see how that is okay all right all right
I could have used that one I would if I
wouldn't if I had it [ __ ] out of here Oh
God's eggs come on
welcome to my weight over here sure are
it's a miserable place all these
beautiful boys walking around the table
but a1 Oh got a - good - I'll take a 1
nevermind wait no wait you don't want
that one you want to get your last piece
do it do it can't do it can't do it nope
enjoy that I could do it I could glass I
mean my piece just left so I don't
really care that much good coming to
your home to me that's the real question
I you know keep asking yourself because
I I've got an imagination one - Wow hey
there's that one God do you know you
must do way do you know what all right
Bob now here comes the six
he's got two in the home all right
what I'm gonna do what am i doing mark
down Magoo's guy I'm gonna get this guy
out because I'm gonna use my other role
to get away from that sorry sorry I was
moving yes yes three four five six yes
please give me a chance so many times I
can't do anything I feel bad I that's so
many without a six now you you just as
many oh look at that good one bud good
role you're wrong you thank you that's
my turn already geez thanks all right
good good roll - yes it's probably -
okay
my turn I think it's still my turn I'm
fine Bob get you six here buddy mm-hmm
was a sweet one it after that music calm
has settled over I think Bob is uh I
think Bob's broken over there okay oops
tied for first Marx tied for first tied
for first all right I missed you
listen I know I know I don't feel like
it's necessary to Oh neat oh no you
can't I'm going for him just wait ah
cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you hover over it it says it so the
way that's right fine I'll reroute you
roll it again fairly certain that was
the one okay but I'm not gonna get a
five well I didn't get five all right I
had that one
what's know you didn't appreciate in I I
had that one alright Bob your turn to
roll five what happens if I can't like
what if I could roll like a five now I
can't do anything
that's on the green line the green line
doesn't count
yeah alright that's a close game
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]